con un pedido de un minuto de silencio
por las víctimas civiles del conflicto
en ucrania el mandatario ucraniano
volodymyr selenski realizó una
intervención ante la asamblea nacional
francesa haciendo un llamado a los
legisladores franceses para hacer todo
lo posible para cesar la guerra en
ucrania nos esperamos de francia- su
liderazgo
que puedan lograr que rusia busque la
paz para poner fin a esta guerra contra
la libertad contra la igualdad contra la
fraternidad
contra
todo lo que hizo que europa esté unida
que sea libre
diversa
esperamos de francia su liderazgo
y la restauración para la restauración
de la integridad territorial de ucrania
tal y como ha hecho en otros encuentros
con parlamentarios mundiales selenski
reiteró su pedido a los europeos a
imponer sanciones más duras contra el
kremlin así como el envío de más
material y apoyo armamentístico cuando
está a punto de cumplirse un mes del
inicio de la invasión rusa ucrania el
próximo 24 de marzo el líder ucraniano
también llamó a las empresas francesas
abandonar moscú para que la libertad no
pierda el mundo debe apoyarla con
sanciones contra el agresor cada semana
en europa hay sanciones las empresas
francesas deben irse del mercado ruso
o no
son todas deben dejar de ser
responsables por financiar la máquina de
guerra de rusia este miércoles un grupo
de senadores se concentraron frente a la
embajada de rusia en parís acompañó los
tricolores en un llamamiento humanitario
para exigir al kremlin que respete el
derecho internacional y permita la
entrega de suministros a la población
ucraniana